my name is Gabriella to Lorenzo and
judy's convinced me to share a mean
whiteboard revelation as a pre-service
teacher everything for me like me has
been the revelation and particularly
mature age so where I've come from very
much the traditional way of teaching
last year I did a prac at a selected
school and apart from knowing that these
children were really beautifully gifted
I knew nothing else didn't know what
else to expect one of the more
inspirational videos I'd seen before
heading out was a two-part series that
BBC documentaries have put out feeling
William if you haven't seen it have a
look a couple of hours worth and it's
following him on film in a school in the
UK and it's where you theories or
theories of teaching meet practice and
there's quite an explosion of concepts
and one was the mini whiteboard and I'll
enough tit I just thought this sort of
energy that we've already seen could
really be generated with with students
doing what they were doing so this is
what I was expecting so students really
filling out white boards with wanting to
share where they're at but this is what
I've got so imagine is a circle geometry
there's an image up on the board what
are you looking at what's the question
just explain tell me what you're looking
at and this is what I got no one at the
back they saw the add-ins obviously is
the teacher I certainly didn't see as
well so I was concerned a bit
disillusioned so that is what I saw what
do I do so I thought I'd
cheated work your hands so get these
students to somehow share the angst and
still at least get some more cognitive
conflict around what they were sharing
so hopefully what goes on these boards
is better for their learning their
collaboration but more than anything for
me is the teacher and professor booth
share this a lot I'm most concerned
about how I'm going to get across all of
the individuals in the schoolroom open
above the involuntary that eyeliner
through the class so for me this is
something that I really will persist and
I will do in the next prac and the other
big advantage as a teacher I only have
to carry up as many white ball